[Music]
working in Vienna at the turn of the
20th century he began his career as a
neurologist before pioneering the
discipline of psychoanalysis he proposed
that people are motivated by unconscious
desires and repressed memories and their
problems can be addressed by making
those motivations conscious through talk
therapy his influence towers above that
of all other psychologists in the public
eye but was Sigmund Freud write about
human nature and were his methods
scientific order order today on the
stand we have dad ahem no your honor
this is dr. Sigmund Freud one of the
most innovative thinkers in the history
of psychology an egomaniac who
propagated pseudo scientific theories
well which is he tackled issues medicine
refused to address Freud's private
practice treated women who suffered from
what was called hysteria at the time and
their complaints hadn't been taken
seriously at all from the women with
depression he treated initially to World
War one veterans with PTSD
Freud's talking cure worked and the
visibility he gave his patients forced
the medical establishment to acknowledge
their psychological disorders were real
he certainly didn't help all his
patients
Freud was convinced that our behavior is
shaped by unconscious urges and
repressed memories he invented baseless
unconscious or irrational drivers behind
the behavior of trauma survivors and
caused real harm how that he
misrepresented some of his most famous
case studies claiming his treatment had
cured patients when in fact they had
gotten worse later therapists influenced
by his theories coaxed their patients
into recovering supposedly repressed
memories of childhood abuse that never
happened
lives and families were torn apart you
can't blame Freud fillet to miss
applications of his work that would be
projecting plenty of his ideas were
harmful without any misapplication he
viewed homosexuality as a developmental
glitch
he coined the term penis envy meaning
women are haunted for life by their lack
of penises fraud was a product of his
era yes some of the specifics were
flawed but he created a new space for
future scientists to explore investigate
and build upon modern therapy techniques
that millions of people rely on came out
of the work he started with
psychoanalysis and today everyone knows
there's an unconscious that idea was
popularized by Freud psychologists today
only believe in a cognitive unconscious
the fact that you aren't aware of
everything going on at a given moment
Freud took this idea way too far
ascribing deep meaning to everything he
built his theories on scientific ideas
that were outdated even in his own time
not just by today's standards for
example he thought individual psychology
is derived from the biological
inheritance of events in ancient history
and I mean ancient like the Ice Age or
the killing of Moses Freud and his
closest allies actually believed these
pre historical traumas had ongoing
impacts on human psychology he thought
that the phase of cold indifference to
sexuality during pubescence was
literally an echo of the Ice Age with
fantastical beliefs like these how can
we take him seriously any renowned
thinker from centuries past has ideas
that seem fantastical by today's
standards but we can't discount their
influence on this basis Freud was an
innovator Lincoln ideas across many
fields his concepts have become everyday
terms that shape how we understand and
talk about our own experiences the
Oedipus complex ego and it defense
mechanisms death wishes all Freud but
Freud didn't present himself as a social
theorist he insisted that his work was
scientific are you saying he repressed
inconvenient facts
Freud's theories were unfalsifiable wait
so you're saying he was right
no his ideas were framed so that there's
no way to empirically verify them Freud
didn't even necessarily believe in the
psychoanalysis he was pedaling he was
pessimistic about the impact of therapy
what I think I need to lie down
many of Sigmund Freud's ideas don't hold
up to modern science and his clinical
practices don't meet today's ethical
standards at the same time he sparked a
revolution in psychology and society and
created a vocabulary for discussing
emotion Freud made his share of mistakes
but is a thinker responsible for how
subsequent generations put their ideas
to use do they deserve the blame credit
or redemption when we put history on
trial
Freud was fascinated by sleep and
believed that analyzing dreams could
reveal repressed desires but is that
true over 100 years later what do we
even know about sleep if you're
interested in learning more about the
vital hours you spend unconscious
we recommend why we sleep a
groundbreaking book that examines how we
can harness the transformative power of
sleep to change our lives for the better
visit audible.com slash ted-ed to
download a free copy
[Music]